用女读者的眼睛，戏读，文学，艺术，当代生活，我们在戏读中介入世界，在闲谈中想象生活的其他可能。
欢迎收听姐姐好读。
我觉得毕业的时候常常会困惑我，这个事情真的是我想做的嘛。
打开人生的一个方法就是，不是我爱什么去做什么，而是我做了什么，就想方设法去爱这件事。
我觉得往前看的人是不同的，就是艺术家是要停留在某处的人。
我不是你。
大姐,I'm not an artist.。
听众朋友们大家好，欢迎收听姐姐好读。
今天是我们的毕业季特别节目。
我是每次毕业都很开心的姐姐希希。
大家好，我是每次毕业都没那么开心的老元。
待会可以展开讲一讲。
大家好，我是每次毕业都很平静。
感觉是这样，但是毕业过很多次的小礁。
小礁是我们这里的毕业王者。
因为六月份是毕业的季节。
想通过这期节目来分享一下毕业这件事情，对于人生到底是怎样的一个意义。
先问问诸位，你们毕业了几次？
我们这样算吧，就是高中毕业有义无教育之后。
对，义无教育之后，就是高中毕业算第一次毕业。
你们毕业了几次？
我毕业了三次。
那下一个是我，我毕业了四次，毕业过五次。
因为我读过两个硕士。
对，小礁姐姐在英国和法国都读了硕士。
所以的确是资深毕业人士。
对。
这么多次的毕业当中，你们印象最深刻的是哪一次呢？
或者说现在，你还有没有对毕业的画面？
因为我们年纪也不小了，离毕业也有一些距离了。
我印象最深就是我硕士毕业的时候。
因为我硕士毕业刚刚赶上疫情，
疫情刚刚开始最严重的时候，
所以我是线上达遍。
然后达遍完了之后，因为各种原因，
拖了好长时间，
我是在第二年春节之前，
才拿到自己的毕业证、绝位证。
我是一个人开车去的，
落在学校门口，像交换情报一样，
然后出来一个人，
就偷偷地交换的毕业证词。
然后我就拿着，然后就马上开车回家。
那天呢，我记得回家的路上，
看到了特别大的夕阳，
然后那个夕阳特别漂亮，特别大，
然后我觉得如果有一天我发财了，
我去马尔代夫看到那个夕阳，
也未必有那天那么好看。
而且当天北京因为风控了，
没什么人也没什么车，
然后非常的孤独。
这个时候我在车，
好失忆的画面。
看着我的毕业证和绝位证，
放声大笑。
我终于不用再读书了，
真的，我当时就想，
我终于这辈子不用再上学了，
我开心死了。
我就觉得说，
我这辈子终于不用再读书了，
我终于离开学校了，
我现在都能想到，
然后我在那个车里看到一轮夕阳，
只有我一个人，
然后我放声大笑，
我想说别那么神经，忍住，
然后但是我越笑越开心，
越笑越开心。
我都被感染了，
为你开心，
快乐的时刻。
我先讲一下，
就我今天的上衣，
是我博士答辩的时候穿的。
我当时就说，
我终于毕业了，
就跟你一样，
我六年的博士生涯终于毕业了，
所以我就惊心挑选了，
我的答辩套装，
所以这个就是我那天穿的上衣，
然后我这个裙子我给大家看一下，
是我本科毕业手穿的，
是一件格子身材，
这些年从来没有毕业。
所以今天我是把我10年的学生生涯，
都穿在了身上，
这个是我本科毕业穿的格子裙，
冰箱最深的毕业的时刻，
北京的夏夜，
在这个校园里的下城广场，
一个阶梯的地方，
和朋友们喝酒喝到了早上六点，
我就穿着这个裙子，
当时还有一张照片，
就每个人脸上又兴奋又迷茫，
所以我想起来觉得真的很开心，
就是很幸福的一些回忆，
也不知道在干什么，也有一些迷茫，
但是就是很快乐，
就是10年前毕业的时候，
感觉我们真的是，
会比现在的大学生要放松很多，
我觉得我当大学生的时候，
我对这种职业发展课都是吃这一笔，
那个是我分数最低的课，
因为我根本不在乎，
但是轮到，
比如说我们给大一行生教课的时候，
我就记得才大一，
那个学生就会说，
老师，你觉得我应该怎么规划我的职业？
然后我就跟他说，
为师也没有规划出来，
他说我30几岁了，
也不知道职业在哪里，
就感觉现在真的大家都很焦虑，
所以这期节目我们也是，
想分享一些听众的来搞，
以及聊一聊，
就是我们对毕业这件事的一些想法，
那小焦的毕业呢？
你有没有印象深刻的毕业时刻？
刚刚希希说了轻松的，
我这个就有一点不太轻松，
就不好意思了，
荒林秀最近有一本新书，
也有了终一本，
叫地狱考，
讲的就是一个独博的女孩子，
他想要准时毕业，
但是他的导师去世了，
然后他就要到地狱里去把他的导师救出来，
为了能准时毕业的这么一个故事框架，
我其实是经历了类似的事，
不是说去地狱救我的导师，
但是我就是在快要毕业的那半年，
大家都找不到我的导师，
我也找不到，
于是我就一直等，
等，等，等，
等到我要是再不毕业，
我就没有办法回来，
跟希希做那份下一步的工作了，
所以我就在那个夏天的最后的时刻，
重新改组了我的博士论文答辩委员会，
就是在最后一刻，
急急忙忙在网上答辩毕业了，
我就在非常迷茫，
然后同时还不知道自己的导师在哪里，
然后也不知道怎么就毕业了，
就急急忙忙的情况下，
我就踏上了回国的归程，
当时坐在那个飞机上，
我真的我就想我是谁，我在哪儿，
我为什么会在这种完全悬空的感觉中毕业了，
对对对，就没有任何的确定感，
我感觉可能跟现在的很多年轻人，
反而有点像，
因为当时的特殊情况，
虽然你这个情况很特殊，
但是我觉得你描述的那种感受，
就是玄智，然后不确定性，
也是很多人毕业的时候，
在面临的这种感受，
那种仓促的感觉，
我觉得其实也是挺常见的，
就是能从容的毕业，
是很幸运的，
就能好好地庆祝，
然后那种仓促的时候，
你就会想，
我下一步脚已经卖出去了，
上一步还没有解决问题呢，
那种感觉，
就是是我当时的心情。
接下来呢，
我们就来分享一些听友的来信，
我觉得这些来信都很精准地描述出了。
毕业的某一种心情，
这位来信的听友叫做楚楚，
他说迷茫吗，
高中时我几乎是班里最确定。
以后要学什么专业的人，
如果不从事这个职业，
我将后悔终生，
所以呢他就顺利地上了大学，
研究生也去到了这个专业最好的院校，
然后后悔了，
他说,
我现在暂时不迷茫，
因为如果就这么顺水推舟地走下去，
也能就业，
但实习过后，
我已经知道那不是我想要的生活，
我无法对这种劳动产生激情，
改行吗？
一是我不知道自己能做什么，
二是家人觉得现在的专业很好，
希望这不是无病身体，
也是会产生很多共鸣的一种心情，
借个人话又有普遍性的一种表达，
写得很好，
而且是随着自己的激情，
做了一些选择，
但是经历了一些时间，
却发现好像跟自己的热爱并不那么相关，
他说他无法对这种劳动产生激情，
我觉得这个是很多人毕业的时候会想的问题，
我真的想继续做这个专业的事情吗？
如果我要转行，
那是不是意味着我要从零开始？
我觉得这封信真的很真实，
像十年前的我写的线文，
我想说就是可能很真实，
可能大家都会有这样的阶段，
我觉得这封信挺奢侈的，
因为我觉得他在讲激情，
我觉得其实追求激情是一件挺奢侈的事情，
我有很长一段时间，
我自己面临的问题是，
我觉得激情是奢侈品，
你不能去追求激情。
我觉得毕业的时候常常会困惑，
就这个事情真的是我想做的吗？
就是我怎么找到人生的热爱？
这个是我的真心话，
我觉得有这种困惑，
其实是一件好事。
因为怎么说呢？
你还在寻找，
你还在寻找你的激情，
你的标准没有被模糊，
你心里真的你知道，
就是有很长一段时间，
我的困惑，
因为我麻木，
我做这个也可以，
做那个也可以，
我没有激情。
之前我跟希希说，
我最羡慕她身上的，
就是她很有激情。
就我觉得跟她在一起，
她做什么，她都啊，
很开心，她听说有能量，
然后完了之后呢，
我就觉得说，
不管事儿大事小，
就很开心，
你就觉得被这种能量感染，
而且你也能感觉到，
希希她特别知道，
她自己想做什么。
我觉得，
只有前半句是对的，
就是我觉得这封信，
特别有代表性，
其实,
很多人如果说，
你一直就说，
我就是要赚钱，
我就是要发财，
或者我就是要当官，
你不会有这个困惑，
你不会说，
我的激情到底是什么，
你只会说，
我怎么能够，
更快地积累财富，
那个是目标很单一的，
然后,
刚刚老元讲的，
就是我很有激情，
但我其实是，
一直激情的不知道在干嘛，
我觉得这个是我身上，
特别,
学生气的部分，
就是我老想找到那个，
我能百分百，
发挥潜力的地方，
在寻找自己的子弯，
对,
我就在任何的方面，
我都是这样，
我就觉得，
这个是我，
也特别想跟，
两位姐姐讨论的，
因为小娇小时候，
不是打乒乓球的嘛，
你是运动员，
然后我小时候，
我的整个中学时代，
都在搞理科竞赛，
我初中学，
数学竞赛，
高中学，
计算机竞赛，
我觉得，
我也是，
某种程度上的这个，
不算体育生吧，
但是就是有这个，
竞技的部分，
就会让我觉得，
首先一，
我特别相信这个，
maritalocracy,。
就是这个，
闲能主义，
当然也翻译成，
优技主义，
但是我觉得，
里面还有一点点不同，
因为我理解的这个，
maritalocracy,。
就是你得找到那个，
你能够，
最大化放大，
你自己的，
潜能的东西，
然后你去做，
百分之一百，
所以我就老觉得，
这个不是，
我就得换，
所以我就老在，
这个,
寻找的过程当中，
当然这里面，
也有一点，
黄旺的成分，
就觉得，
你自己是个东西，
你如果觉得我，
就是什么都不是，
你不会说，
我一定要找到一个，
我百分之百的，
潜能的所在，
所以,
我会觉得，
我伪看这些，
求学的生活，
我就会想说，
人是不是一定要，
先找到激情，
再用力呢？
我真的很难回答，
因为我学习太困难，
当然我这个，
也不是说，
因为我学习不好，
我就摆烂，
什么的，
我就是会觉得说，
我有激情的地方，
我也很吃力，
然后那个激情，
我就消散了，
可是你不会觉得吗？
就是,
比如说小孩，
你要培养他，
你就说，
他可以试试那个，
说不定他就特别，
擅长这个，
然后,
比如说我在做A的时候，
我就会想说，
那万一我做B，
可以做成世界一流呢？
这就是我心态的不一样，
我跟你讲，
我做A的时候还行，
我就想说，
天呐,
我可就可，
就是做吧，
我其实，
千万不要再去尝试了，
因为我一尝试，
我做别的，
我就好不容易靠时间，
换空间积累起来的，
这一点点优势，
就肯定就不想了，
我觉得首先要定义激情，
就是每一个人，
定义这个东西，
肯定是不一样的，
我,
这个人，
对我做所有事情和选择，
只有一个标准，
就是这个事情，
能不能让我，
快乐和身心健康，
所以如果说，
就是,
让我来定义，
刚刚大家说的这个激情，
如果定义成身心健康，
那我确实是在，
不停地寻找这个，
我在这儿和嘻嘻有一个，
截然相反的，
就嘻嘻他是要，
追求卓越，
他的激情是要找自己，
能够卓越的那个东西，
我的激情是那个，
不能把我累着的那个东西，
就是我能做他，
很开心，
与此同时我不费力，
我觉得这个，
是我要选择的东西，
我不一定卓越，
但是我做这事，
就是心情好，
并且,
我没有那么累，
让我能休息，
我身心健康，
所以,
你误得比较早，
你很早就以自我为标准，
因为我偏头痛，
我就是累着了，
我就倒在床上，
动不了了，
所以我一定就是要，
就是把激情定义成，
不能把自己累着，
身心健康的前提下，
我这个事，
我还做得比较开心，
就是我的选择，
然后哪怕这个世界上，
有一些其他事，
我做他能做的卓越，
那个,
如果把我累着了，
或者是，
无论是身体，
还是心理，
都给我压力了，
那个事也我会远离，
我觉得可以讲一个具体的事，
是,
因为我是不太有激情的人，
然后呢，说到激情，
我就想到，
这是我是义考，
然后我家里，
没有任何人，
总是文艺工作，
就我父母唱歌，
都是五音不全的那种，
然后他们就觉得，
没有那个神经，
然后而且，
大家对义考都会有一些，
觉得说，
你要去义考，
对于我们家里人来说，
就像余说，
我要飞一样，
他们就觉得这个东西，
他们无法理解，
然后呢，
我不知道那个激情，
是来源于对抗，
还是来源于什么，
有一次，
我就给我爸改电话，
我说，我一定要去考试，
我这辈子有没有做这个，
因为我们之前，
一直有一些对抗，
他就不希望我去做这个事情，
我说完这句话之后，
我爸就陷入了，
长久的沉默，
然后过了一段时间，
他又给我打电话，
他说,
我觉得，
如果你真的确定，
这个事情，
是你一辈子想做的，
我在你身上，
感受到了那种激情，
并且那种激情，
说服了我，
我愿意支持你去尝试，
然后,
后来我才能够，
去参加一考，
我当时甚至，
当然这个有点，
反驳封建比性，
我当时甚至觉得，
如果家里人，
不支持我去一考，
我就要自己赚钱，
去考试，
那我,
还没有全年，
我能干什么呢，
我就买了一本，
首相书，
我一块钱，
自己学首相，
你还说，
你没有激情，
这个太有激情了吧，
然后呢，
我就想说，
我就靠给人看，
首相专程，
我就刻于时间，
我就看一个，
就一百块钱，
然后,
这件事呢，
确实是真话，
当然我，
我后面就，
就家里人，
还是支持我，
所以那个，
技能也没有用上，
然后后面也忘了，
学义不尽，
然后,
但是我就觉得，
在那个时候，
是能感觉到激情，
可是那封信，
就说到，
就是,
他也上了自己，
理想的专业，
然后,
感觉到，
就是有一种，
激情破灭的，
那种感觉，
然后这个我也，
完全深有体会，
因为我，
考的,
依考的学校，
还是比较难的，
是,
然后我也是，
很难的考上了，
全国最好的导演戏，
就那样吧，
就,
就不说了，
但是也很难的考上了，
考上了之后，
我就会觉得，
在里面，
也有很多让我，
痛苦的东西，
然后包括我自己，
发现自己，
其实根本就，
不适合做这个事情，
我到底要干什么，
其实到现在为止，
我也没有答案，
但是我，
听到CC说这封信的时候，
我就突然回想起来，
给我爸打的那个电话，
然后他说，
之前我们一直都，
不支持，
然后我就会觉得说，
激情它本身是有一种力量，
但是激情这个东西，
就像风一样，
风来的时候呢，
我们就，
让风带着我们，
往前走一走，
然后没有风的时候呢，
就歇一歇，
我觉得这样是不是会，
比较好，
就是激情，
是非常好的一个东西，
我太同意老远说的，
就是激情来的时候，
就去追逐它，
没有激情的时候，
也不要消沉，
就是因为这个激情，
这个东西，
它也有它的反面，
你容易被这个东西，
迷惑之后，
会被别人利用，
对吧，就是有人，
特别是我们做，
这些文学，
文艺相关工作的，
学术，艺术，
就是很多，
没不给钱的工作，
它就是用激情，
还披尾你，
还说你，
你不能吃这些苦，
说明你爱得不够深，
是,
所以就是，
你如果去干一个，
所谓,
更实际的工作，
没有激情的工作，
人家会，
按照你的能力，
按照你付出的努力，
给你酬劳，
但是在这些，
激情的领域里面，
你就经常，
会被别人，
白白的，
就是,
利用你的劳动力，
而用激情作为一个用，
所以我觉得，
无论,
是不是要追逐激情，
都有一个原则，
就是,
你自己，
是最重要的，
嗯,
你自己的感受，
是最重要的，
也不要，
被这个激情，
所绑架的，
就是这种感觉，
而且我真的觉得，
激情,
就是会变的，
就是疯，
可能我们三个人里面，
我是对激情，
或者说，
我对这个，
意义,
一直有一种执念，
就是我老觉得，
我要做，
不仅是我能做好的事情，
而且是我，
特别相信的事情，
我觉得，
有意义，
有价值的事情，
然后呢，
这个事情就老变，
即使到三十多岁，
我还在说，
我的,
潜能在哪里，
我的激情在哪里，
但是呢，
我现在，
回看我的，
这么多的人生选择，
我会觉得，
至少,
有两点，
是可以，
让我过得，
比较开心的，
一点,
就是感受到激情，
就是去追逐的，
就是在那个，
有风的时候，
就迎风而去，
就让自己，
乘着那个激情的风，
去做一些，
跟你平时不一样的，
事情,
不管是，
就是,
事业啊，
工作啊，
学业啊，
然后,
生活啊，
我觉得，
种种,
就是有激情的那个瞬间，
是很难得的，
二十,
我觉得就是，
百分百投入，
因为这样，
即使,
激情消失，
也不会后悔，
比如说，
做过课，
我就觉得，
哎，挺好玩，
挺有激情，
但是我也不能说，
这个就是，
世界上最适合我的工作，
但是呢，
爱美讲，
有最佳播客讲王，
那是我们的目标，
我说,
我不知道，
奥斯卡没有，
爱美讲有，
所以呢，
我就会，
我就觉得，
嗯,
也很好玩，
那,
对于这封来信，
来说,
因为它已经考进了，
这个专业，
最好的院校，
所以它已经在一个，
很多人都希望，
在的位置了，
它可以在，
在做这个事情的，
同时,
再看一看，
自己有什么，
别的想做的事情，
接下来呢，
我想问一个问题，
我想,
我们来评价一下，
自己的社会化程度，
因为这个就是，
我经常在，
小红书的帖子里面看到，
我们先不定义，
什么是社会化，
就是,
凭你自己的理解，
你觉得，
自己毕业多年后，
社会化程度，
高吗?
对,
要不然，
我来读一下，
就是有，
非常可爱的，
听众朋友投稿说的，
然后一位，
大三同学的投稿，
如果给现在的，
自己打分，
我只能打四分，
我学会了，
独自相处，
时期报告，
甚至开始，
理解职场里，
那些没说出口的，
潜台词，
但我依然会，
在深夜怀疑，
还没有真正毕业，
身边的人，
都说我，
斑味很重，
这要算，
社会化了吗？
还是,
只是被迫早输，
我觉得，
社会化，
不该只是，
学会妥协，
而是,
找到自己的坐标，
而我还在，
建立坐标的过程中，
就是,
大家都太谦虚了，
才给自己打四分，
对,
大三就有班位了，
这怎么才四分呢？
然后,
还有一个朋友，
也给自己打四分，
说自己的，
社会化程度，
应该是四，
现在,
仅靠着，
本性里的，
善恶观，
在为人处事，
这样的生活，
问题在于，
肯定会吃亏，
但因为，
一直吃小亏，
没有吃大亏，
所以,
并没有打算，
去升级，
我的社会化水平，
而且,
对于,
带人的优点，
也很明显，
省去了，
揣测,
讨巧的环节，
可以更专注的，
摸鱼了，
所以,
我觉得，
这个朋友，
其实,
你也不算，
社会化程度低，
你都想明白了，
你这个情商，
也很高，
听众朋友们，
也可以拿出笔，
来给自己的，
社会化程度，
打一个分，
一到十，
我们每个人，
给自己打分，
也给,
其他两位打分，
我先说，
我给自己，
打五分，
打七点五分，
七点五分，
我给我，
和老元，
都打了五点五分，
给西西，
打了七分，
天呐，我这么高，
那我,
我给自己，
打了六分，
及格,
我给老元，
打了五分，
那我看来是，
看,
这准确的，
就是我们，
我给小娇，
打了七分，
我们可以，
先讲讲，
我们对，
社会化的理解，
或者说，
我们为什么，
给出这个分吧，
我给老元，
就是在我这里，
首先，社会化程度高，
它不见得是一个，
包一词，
我觉得这个是没有，
没有,
包便宜的，
然后呢，
我对老元，
印象特别深的是，
我们那次去，
采访鲁玉，
我们就说，
第二天要穿什么，
之类的，
就是有一些讨论，
然后现场，
老人出现的时候，
他就把那个，
棒球帽，
反着戴，
我就觉得，
因为我觉得，
我是一个，
不能说，
社会化程度高，
但是我是会对这个，
这些事情，
想很多的人，
这些瞬间，
我就觉得，
老元真是个自由人，
这真的是个，
特别洒脱，
哎,
我就觉得很有意思，
所以我给你打了五分，
我觉得你会更，
生活在自己的，
这个标准里面，
不是,
是,
因为我要解释一下，
所以我承认，
这个,
我社会化程度，
不太高，
但是我那个，
棒球帽，
反戴,
不是,
因为我，
如果政治戴的话，
我发现我有点，
遮挡视线，
但是我觉得，
如果社会化程度高的人，
就不应该戴帽子，
就不应该戴帽球帽，
嗯,
我承认，
太可爱了，
我特别想看那个场景，
给小娇打了七分，
是我们之间最高的，
就是因为呢，
我跟小娇，
一起去一些，
这个社交场合，
我就发现，
小娇,
特别会夸奖别人，
嗯,
因为我，
我觉得这一点上，
我就比较困难，
所以我就觉得，
嗯,
小娇,
比我社会化程度要高，
所以这个是，
可能我，
非常粗浅的一个，
定义吧，
就是,
在一个，
不同于你日常生活的场合，
怎么样能够，
看起来有任有余，
嗯,
哎,
我很认同你这个标准，
我觉得你这个标准，
很好,
就是我就是，
比如说，
到一个陌生的场合，
我就会觉得，
哎呀,
完了,
我今天有点，
举诉,
我为什么，
给小娇分数最高，
我要讲一个，
故事,
我们之前去，
拦扣那个活动，
哇,
小娇当时，
真的让我觉得，
她就是一个大人，
嗯,
然后我是一个，
小孩,
然后小娇是去工作的，
我是去给人取外号的，
我就坐在那，
完了之后，
我就感觉，
我自己，
就是,
只是在做一个，
呃,
被携带进去了，
就是那种感觉，
然后我也做不了什么，
而且我必须要说，
小娇真的非常会夸人，
嗯,
小娇夸人的，
厉害的程度，
缺的GBT,
要拜她为师的，
是,
真的,
只要有，
就是小娇的那个，
语言系统，
我觉得，
就是AI不可能取代人类的，
我呢,
跟老元都说，
5.5分,
西西是7分，
我们两个，
5.5分的原因不一样，
然后我觉得，
老元5.5分，
也是就是，
像西西说的，
我觉得老元是一个，
艺术家，
嗯,
就是你是一个，
自由人，
反夸人，
是一个自由人，
你没有被体制，
没迅过，
所以你身上就是，
没有那些，
不得不参与，
社会化，
化与体系的那个痕迹，
训练,
没有那个训练痕迹，
所以那个东西，
不是一个天赋，
它是一个，
选择,
它是一个选择，
而且是一个，
不断你，
不断重复那个过程，
你就会强化那个能力嘛，
你是没有经过那个训练而已，
就是这个意思，
我给西西打7分是，
西西现在是，
创业者了，
要和很多人打交道，
并且还都很成功，
我觉得，
有任有余的，
做了很多，
这个,
跟不同人的，
沟通呀，
推广呀，
我觉得，
所以我，
西西现在，
作为一个创业者，
你已经是7分的，
这个,
社会化，
对不起，
我努力，
比如说，
老元,
那,
三个人的打分里面，
你喜提最低，
你开心吗？
还是你会觉得伤心？
我不开心，
不开心，
但是我确实，
不太会，
我之前，
在电影学院，
读书的时候，
因为很早，
大家就要开始，
其实,
在意效读书的人，
是最早，
接触社会的，
然后,
我们拍作业，
要跟那些登工，
各种,
五花八门的人，
打交道，
我在那呢，
就学到了一个，
小技能，
社会小技能，
是什么呢？
就是,
因为,
你工作完，
要请大家吃饭，
然后,
他们就会喝酒，
然后那个时候呢，
你也要，
给他们敬酒，
倒过来，
就代表着，
我喝光了，
然后呢，
大家就会，
先干为敬，
对，先干为敬，
然后后来，
我就觉得说，
这个东西，
就是我学到的，
一个社会技能，
代表着我很，
真诚,
然后,
我很真实，
真的实践过吗，
我实践了，
我就,
跟他们实践过，
实践过后来，
我就读，
读硕士，
然后完了之后，
老师也是，
吃饭的时候，
我就没有，
动大脑，
因为就形成肌肉记忆了，
然后我说，
老师，来，
这边我干了，
干了，然后这样，
我看到我的，
同学,
和我的老师，
瞳孔地震，
然后就，
所有的人都，
觉得说，
我们这里面，
混入了，
工地的，
包工厂，
然后,
所有的人都伸手说，
别这样，别这样，
然后就说，
不至于不至于，
咱们就是，
放松的，
然后就是那种，
朋友,
同学,
师门,
然后,
欢聚,
我,
非常,
难受,
然后我当时就想，
天呐,
我是一个，
老油条，
但其实，
其实不是，
所以我觉得，
社会化，
这个东西是这样的，
如果你让别人，
感觉到，
你,
你社会化，
程度很高，
但他就不会说，
你是社会人，
如果他说，
你很社会，
那句话，
肯定是，
骂人的，
他也不会，
带,
抱歉,
没有没有没有，
我觉得这个是，
是对的，
这个是对的，
我觉得，
你刚刚讲的那个，
例子太好了，
虽然我们在，
小红书上看到，
很多,
这种,
就是说，
社会化，
程度高，
就是好，
我不想跟，
社会化，
程度低的人，
做朋友，
好像其实，
就变成一种，
情商的，
代名词，
但其实，
在社会学里面，
就是作为，
社会再生产的，
一个重要的机制，
在这个，
比如说，
50年代,
这个,
美国最重要的，
一个社会学家，
这个电机人，
这个 Parsons,。
代表的，
这种,
结构功能主义，
那个里面，
社会化，
就是一个很重要的概念，
就觉得个体，
你要怎么，
变成社会的一份子，
就是你说的，
就是,
我们要学，
我们要模仿，
然后甚至，
有些人会把这个机制，
社会化，
形容成一种，
文化下载，
就该这样，
这样，这样，
这样,
公仇交错，对吧，
然后,
但是,
其实现在这个概念，
在,
虽然在小红书上走红，
但其实，
在社会学里面，
已经不是那么，
核心的一个概念了，
因为很多人，
会对这种说，
我要下载，
这一套，
为人处事的方法，
是有底处的，
因为说，
那这套规定，
到底是谁，
确定的，
这些,
规范,
认为是好的，
是对的事情，
是谁来决定的，
家庭,
它就没有这些资源，
也没有这一套语法，
所以,
我觉得现在，
更多的，
我们讲社会化，
在这个学术里面，
它不见得是一种，
很,
包裔的概念，
很多人，
在比如说，
性别和教育研究里面，
还会大量的使用，
这个Socialization,。
这个概念，
它就会说说，
我们是，
被这种，
高度艳女的文化，
社会化的，
所以,
你长大成人，
这样的，
环境下，
男孩,
就会变成一个，
首先一，
不是一个，
每个人都必须做的事情，
二是,
刚老元说的，
你在这个社会里面，
被认为对的事情，
在另外一个，
环境,
文化环境里面，
会被认为是，
离谱的，
你去跟，
很多人，
你把杯子喝完，
就倒扣，
大家就觉得，
你是哪里来的？
就包括，
有一些地方，
很讲究这个座位，
主座应该做哪儿，
然后这个客人，
应该做哪儿，
但是,
真的要学这些东西吗？
学这些东西，
真的,
延续一些，
糟糕的文化吗？
确实,
所以,
在毕业这个时分，
很多时候，
大家就会对，
踏入社会，
有恐惧，
而且很多人会觉得，
我可能，
就是很，
不擅长，
做这些事情。
这想到我，
我毕业的时候，
我有一个机会，
准确来说，
一个机会，
是进到一个，
互联网大厂，
因为那个时候，
网剧如日中天，
然后我的老师说，
他愿意，
把这个工作推荐给我，
如果我想去的话，
我就可以去到那里，
然后在此之前，
我跟我的好朋友，
然后我们有一个，
聊天,
然后我们就在那个操场，
真的走了，
一个晚上，
走一直走，
一直走，
然后我们就聊个什么话题呢，
说我到底，
要不要去试试，
这个工作，
去大厂，
去真正的联网大厂，
对,
然后我的同学，
跟我说，
我的朋友跟我说，
说鱼儿，
我们都是，
注定,
就是无法融入这个社会的人，
我们都是，
会被社会伤害的人，
所以我们要躲起来，
就是你不要去那种地方，
然后我觉得，
他说的有道理，
然后我就没有去，
没有去，
我就,
就是自由人，
自由人到现在，
然后,
然后就拒绝了
社会化的这个，
机会,
我不应该给你打五分，
为什么？
我想给你打高一点，
不知道，
我这里，
我自己会想，
比如说这个擅长，
然后这种游刃有鱼，
我会觉得，
它是一种，
既是一种能力，
也是一种意愿，
嗯,
是一个心态，
是你愿不愿意这样去做，
愿意做的时候，
你有没有这个能力，
我认为这两点，
是分开的，
就比如说，
我去一个社交场合，
然后,
我想办法说，
我要去，
认识更多的人，
加微信，
不管是为了做研究，
还是为了，
比如说，
我们播客接商务，
但是那个事情，
它,
肯定不是，
让我觉得特别快乐的事情，
就我觉得那个对我来讲，
是消耗体力的，
那这样的情况下，
是,
是因为社会化不够高吗？
I don't know,。
但是,
想象你怎么想？
我觉得，
不是,
我真的是一个，
跟大家思维方式不一样的人，
因为我，
我不会，
用想做不想做，
来定义一些事，
我只是会觉得，
我应不应该做，
需不需要做，
我觉得，
只要这个事我需要做，
这个事对我当下，
是需要的，
我就觉得，
没有,
没有问题，
只要这个事不，
不伤害别人的利益，
无论是去社交呀，
或者是什么的，
我都觉得，
OK,
我完全可以做，
然后我做这个事的时候，
其实很多时候，
我也没有带情感进去，
它是一个，
它就像工作一样，
就是它是一个，
就是,
怎么把激情，
就是你的情感，
跟你做的这个事，
剥离,
在某种程度上，
我觉得，
也许是社会化的一个，
就是,
一个步骤，
因为,
如果你的行为，
跟你的情感，
太多的，
绑定在一起，
那你的行为，
就会,
给你造成很多的，
困扰,
就比如说，
你去稍微做一些，
在情感上，
你并不那么喜欢的事，
比如说，
我一个内向的人，
社交,
我就是之前，
做一个非常小的，
项目的项目经理，
但也要，
很多社交呀，
但是我就觉得，
这个是我该做的工作，
然后,
我就去，
把这个当成一个，
工作干就行了，
我就不会，
把自己的情感，
带到里面，
我就觉得，
我把我的情感，
跟我的工作隔离了，
我慢慢，
我就坐着，
坐着发现，
这个事，
我做的还挺好的，
我就反而有了，
正反馈，
我就觉得，
这个事，
反而我也跟，
我喜欢干这个事，
当我,
干着干着，
我就觉得，
好像也没有什么，
不能干的，
好像也挺开心的，
就是,
所以我觉得，
第一步，
就是,
有一些事，
确实是，
我们必须要做的，
其实,
就把那个，
情感,
跟它稍稍隔离一点，
就不用去想，
我那么沉浸，
在那个环境中，
我觉得，
会让,
卖出那一步，
容易一点，
也许,
也没有什么坏处吧，
说的特别对，
我觉得，
就是,
把我,
放得太大，
而且我觉得，
就是说，
把我限定得太死了，
就比如说，
你刚刚的操场，
谈话,
我觉得，
很多很多的，
毕业生，
也会有这种感觉，
他说,
我不适合去，
人多的地方工作，
因为我，
就是一个很内向的人，
或者说，
我不适合去一些，
要跟领导打交道的工作，
什么的，
就是你，
你会,
提早的，
限定自己说，
我不适合这个，
我不适合那个，
但可能，
然后一开始，
可能有一点不舒服，
后面发现，
也能忍受，
而且你们还很年轻呢，
对啊,
打开人生的一个方法，
就是,
不是我爱什么，
去做什么，
而是我做了什么，
就想方设法，
去爱这件事，
哇，说的好，
真的可以吗？
当然这个，
也是我最近的一个人生感悟，
就是,
因为身体的原因，
我就在想，
这个,
想要让自己的身体好，
就说,
你一定要让你的身体，
承受一些不适，
因为你的身体，
永远在舒适的温度里，
比如说你运动，
你总不让它累，
你不让它酸痛，
然后你不去跑到你历节，
那你的身体，
就不能成长，
你的身体，
就不能激发那些，
让它更健康的因素，
所以一定程度的不舒适，
心理上，
是会帮助你的，
我觉得当代人，
对心理不舒适的，
承受力是，
比以前的人，
要低一点，
对吧,
以前的人，
他面对的社会更恐惧，
而且我们现在也经常说，
留在自己的舒适区，
很好很好，
虽然话是这么说，
但是微微的，
microdosing一点,。
不舒适，
你会发现，
也许，就像希希说的，
你把自己框的那个地方，
是一个你想象的框，
也许,
你比那个能飞的，
远很多很多，
也许,
甚至你有可能，
是一个相反的人格呢，
都说不定，
我觉得，
我,
思考这个问题，
跟你的路径不同，
但是结论是差不多的，
我是一个靠激情，
来驱动的人，
我没有办法说，
我做什么，
就爱上他，
但是呢，
我爱什么，
就去试，
然后试的过程中呢，
因为我爱，
赢,
我想赢，
所以做什么事，
我都想把它搞清楚，
想把它给，
做好,
我做播客，
我也想做成全中国第一名，
所以,
在这个过程当中，
你就会，
一定会有不舒适，
一定会有困难，
但是呢，
你就能够，
让自己，
有那个动力，
去往前走，
所以,
我在想啊，
激情什么时候，
能够,
转化成一种，
更确凿的行动，
就是,
你在做的过程当中，
克服了困难，
获得了成功，
获得了更大的成功，
然后这个时候，
你就能够，
更坚定的往下走，
不然它永远，
只是说，
我喜欢这个，
我感觉我喜欢这个，
而且,
微小的重法会，
也行,
是的,
就一切还是要，
从实践中，
去调整，
是的，是的，
然后,
我们这样会，
特像老人啊，
不会啊，
我觉得，
但是我作为，
经常逃避，
迴避的人，
这一两年，
是另一次散步，
然后对我，
产生了一个，
正面的影响，
就是我也是，
跟一个朋友散步，
然后我就，
一直在跟他讲，
在这个，
工作中的，
所有的不愉快，
很多倒霉的事情，
然后我呢，
讲的也，
卉生,
卉色,
然后也，
也很充满激情，
在讲倒霉的事情下，
真懂,
充满激情，
然后讲的，
卉生,
卉色,
朋友也是，
笑,
然后笑的肚子都疼了，
然后突然，
就沉默了，
隔了一会儿，
他说了一句话，
他说,
所有的人都会遇到，
不顺的事情，
倒霉的事情，
可是呢，
你还是要往前看，
要做,
别的事情，
要做新的事情，
我突然，
往前看，
这三个字，
就是很震撼，
大为震撼，
因为我，
我身边的，
很多朋友，
包括我，
我觉得，
我们都不会往前看，
就是,
我们就会，
停留在，
一个阶段，
所以我，
我现在，
在学习往前看，
我觉得往前看，
是一个，
挺重要的事情，
我有一个，
就是,
完全,
我个人化的观察，
我觉得，
往前看的人，
是普通人，
就是,
艺术家，
是要停留在某处的人，
我不是艺术家，
大为,
因为,
我在想，
就是,
创作这件事，
我不是艺术家，
因为,
我在想，
因为我在想，
就是,
好的创作者，
我总感觉，
就是,
因为有那个原地在，
所以才能，
展现出来，
这个,
相对的这个时间，
然后,
如果没有原地，
总在往前走的人，
没有过去的人，
他是没有办法，
写作的，
创作的，
我觉得那个原地，
那个过去，
对那个东西的，
执着,
或者对那个东西的，
反复的深挖，
其实是，
作家呀，
艺术家呀，
常有的一种，
创作母题，
创作的原籍，
原神,
就是一个，
童年的阴影，
可能是很多，
大作家，
一辈子反复回到的，
那些,
李安，对吧，
然后有的是一个，
就是,
离题,
他会反复回到那个，
但王源不是艺术家，
你往前走，
妹妹,
但是我也，
但我也走不动，
你会遗憾，
你没有进入大厂，
洗礼吗？
因为我在大厂的朋友，
我有时候，
听他们讲里面的人计，
人事关系，
这个,
里面的内斗，
然后都觉得，
天哪,
真的是征环传的成绩，
这个故事的后续是，
是劝我不要，
进大厂的朋友，
进了大厂，
然后呢，
然后他，
去的,
自己跳动，
三天之后走了，
离职了，
他说,
员儿啊，
这个地方，
自己,
心脏,
和自己只能跳动，
然后,
然后他就离职了，
离职了之后，
然后,
会声会色，
边哭边演，
跟我说，
自己有多么的恐怖，
然后,
还有说我，
我真的受不了了，
他说,
你知道吗，
我下班了，
那个,
自己的时间都没有，
是,
然后我朋友现在就，
离职了，
三天,
对,
所以呢，
这个毕业这期，
虽然我们有来搞，
我们也会，
胡说一些道理，
但是,
总体上来讲，
我们都是社会化程度，
比较低的人，
我们也没有什么大厂的，
洗礼,
人生的这个，
智慧可以分享，
毕业了五次，
对,
有很多很多，
毕业的经验，
所以我们就是，
大家就是，
听着好玩，
然后也，
关于在评论区，
对,
那我想问问，
你们有没有，
毕业时，
很相信的，
一条法则，
比如说，
第一份工作很重要啊，
或者是，
说,
啊趁年轻，
要多视错呀，
就是你们会，
在当时，
相信什么，
现在还相信，
那在听你们的，
答案之前，
先来给大家，
读一封信，
来自,
毛茂,
那段时间，
正是我，
备考,
跨专业，
考研的阶段，
整个人，
对不确定的结果，
去,
但如今，
真正的毕业时刻，
降临在我眼前，
我的心，
反而平静下来，
虽然跨考，
真的下案了，
虽然真的，
毕业几失业了，
但是心，
却奇异的，
平静了下来，
毕业,
只是我一路，
生学的生涯，
暂时割钱，
我依然，
在追求，
一种,
致实的生活，
所以,
不会停步，
写得,
感情很充沛的，
一封信，
我毕业的时候，
特别,
相信的一个词，
就是坚持，
因为,
从小,
周围的人都会说，
我不够坚持，
我学过小提琴，
学过书法，
然后学过，
什么,
各种七七八八的东西，
都没有走到最后，
因为我真的很喜欢，
写剧本，
我想,
我一定要坚持，
我要,
跟住,
然后就因为这个想法，
我在毕业之后，
吃了很多口，
而且是毫无意义的，
每当我退却的时候，
我就告诉自己，
跟住,
然后又吃了很多，
没有意义的，
真的很酷，
听老元讲过一些，
写剧本的日子，
我真的觉得，
好可怕，
我问过那个，
字节跳动的朋友，
我说是字节苦玩，
写剧本，
他说,
写剧本比字节苦多，
我还记得，
我刚认识老家的时候，
你说你写剧本的，
岁月是，
唯独十二仔，
真是太搞笑了，
知道,
真的有一天，
就是毫无症状的疯愧，
你就想吐，
然后我就从这个事情里面，
得到了一个感受，
就是,
坚持是一个很好的词，
这个世界上的优点，
它必须要成对的出现，
缺点,
它可以是单蹦的，
但是优点必须要成对的出现，
怎么说，
坚持的多少是谁？
就是,
比如说，
你是善良，
如果你善良是一个很好的优点，
但是你一定要搭配一个，
编辑,
比如说，
勇敢是一个很好的，
品质,
但是你一定要搭配智慧，
你要不然就猛夫嘛，
忍耐也是一个，
非常好的品质，
但是你一定要自爱，
对,
它的优点，
你一定要是，
成双成对的出现的，
好有道理，
好有折理，
今天的第一条折理，
如果说，
这个坚持，
需要搭配一个，
什么优点的话，
我之前觉得，
需要搭配智慧，
你要寻找正确的方向，
需要搭配这些，
如果你们知道，
坚持,
需要搭配一个，
要搭配，
我想想看，
不能坚持吃食，
就是坚持，
坚持,
意识器，
所以我，
我的文区，
太累了，
先入第二场，
我已经疯了，
坚持,
要和快乐，
搭配在一起，
天呐,
你抢了我的台词，
真的,
你小叫你觉得呢？
我觉得，
我刚刚想的是，
坚持,
至少是得和健康，
反正快乐差不多吧，
就是你身心健康吧，
你坚持，
有个前提嘛，
就觉得，
我之前觉得坚持，
就是你要在正确的方向，
但是你为了这个，
正确的方向，
你是可以忍受痛苦，
因为有些时候，
正确的东西，
它有些时候，
来之不易，
对，它很痛苦，
你要痛苦，
对，你要通过痛苦，
你要通过折磨，
然后来佐证他们的正确，
但是我现在觉得，
真的有一个词被忽略了，
就是快乐，
因为这个词，
你会觉得它不够社会化，
你就追求快乐这个东西，
就是小孩，
对，你像在追求，
每天要吃零食一样，
你如果是一个社会化，
沉重很高的人，
你就应该尽量的，
去剥离自己的情绪，
从这个厉害，
判断,
做一个成熟的大人，
但是,
我现在觉得，
这个世界，
真的不止一种正确答案，
这也是我觉得，
社会比学校好的，
因为学校，
就是正确的，
只有一套考证，
对啊，很单一，
如果你被排除在这个考证之外，
那你就是 nothing，
但是你在社会，
只要你能找到你自己的价值，
然后别人有一错人，
也认可你的价值，
你就是可以活得很好嘛，
我如果造会几年，
我看你觉得做播客，
是一个，
就它不是一个正确的事情，
它就是个事儿，
对，它就是，
它是个零食，
对，姐妹之间的娱乐，对吧，
然后呢，
周末闲一下，
自己录一录，
然后假装自己再搞点自媒体，
然后,
它就不是一个正确的事情，
但是我必须说，
就是这两年，
我觉得做播客，
真的挺开心的，
就每一次，
非常小的成就，
就大家都特别开心，
然后互相赞美，
在群里，
哇，太开心了，
真的,
就到现在，
做播客，
已经两年多了，
我感觉才半年，
就我觉得，
这种谈止一回间的感觉，
我觉得就是快乐的力量，
而且我真的要说，
我觉得，
老元的态度，
积极了很多，
积情都慢慢渗出来了，
而且,
我觉得刚刚老元讲的，
这个快乐，
也让我想到之前，
我们最早的那封信，
讲积情，
讲热爱，
我觉得快乐，
是一个，
更有用的标准，
因为积情，
或者热爱，
尤其热爱，
它显得很大，
承诺都很大，
但是我快乐，
它是一种，
我当下的，
决心的反应，
所以我觉得，
与其追求一生的热爱，
不如找到当下的快乐，
说得好，
什么让你高兴，
你就做这，
真的,
只要别犯法就行，
是,
是不能犯法，
我觉得我毕业的时候，
我现在回想起来，
我每一次毕业，
都挺确认的，
因为我相信了一个法则，
就是要去，
更远的远方，
比如说，
这个高中毕业，
当时可以选择，
是去上海，
去北京，
我就觉得，
北京更远，
在我的印象中，
因为我不了解，
我就觉得，
它更文艺，
更有理想气息，
大学毕业，
要出去留学，
也是因为我，
整个大学期间，
就是,
在宿舍里面，
沉迷看美剧，
你就觉得，
我想去，
电视剧里的世界，
所以呢，
就是,
我到现在，
其实还是很相信，
这个法则，
我觉得在年轻的时候，
在能力范围之内，
可以去到大城市，
可以尽量的去，
看更大的世界，
就不一定是，
说出国啊，
我就觉得，
比如说，
去到大城市，
然后呢，
就这个过程当中，
你就会发现，
社会是多远的，
如果你一直生活在一个，
很封闭的小社会，
每个人都遵循，
同一套社会法则，
这个时候我们聊，
你要不要社会化，
就只有一个选择，
就是我加入，
还是不加入，
就是我举杯，
要不要干杯，
要不要把杯子倒扣，
就只有这样一条法则，
但是如果，
在我选择，
我加入不加入之前，
我先跳出来，
先去不同的城市，
不同的行业，
去感受这种，
不同的社会的形态，
当你睁眼看社会以后，
你就会发现，
哎,
原来世界不止一种规则，
你在这里，
需要喝完酒，干杯，倒扣，
还要签什么自发三杯，
你在那个地方，
大家觉得你喝酒，
就是一个很奇怪的事情，
对吧,
我们一起工作，
就不需要一起喝酒，
不需要在酒桌上，
才能谈成事情，
那你就会发现，
有很多很多不同的规则，
那这个时候，
你就可以采取拿来主意，
你就可以建立自己的社会规则，
你就可以有创造性的，
去想说，
这个我认同，
我接受，
这些东西，
我厌恶，
那我就不接受，
我就不加入，
而且你可以慢慢的找到，
让你能够相对舒服，
且发挥潜能的一个小社会，
当然在这个理想的状况下，
就比如说，
我不适合去，
跟很多人打交道，
那我可以搞创作，
可以在一个工作室的形态里面，
工作,
所以我会觉得，
可能,
不用那么早的，
就是,
选好自己的路线，
不用,
在大一的时候，
就规划好自己，
全部的人生，
因为真的没有办法，
这样去规划，
是的,
所以我的那个法则，
就是延续，
细细和老远说，
当然这个，
也是我自己的，
一样了，
我哪怕是，
最后一次，
毕业的时候，
已经年龄不小了，
但我仍然觉得，
自己很年轻，
因为我的家里人很好，
我说,
你这么年轻，
你想干什么，
就干什么，
其实,
我感觉，
我想说的就是，
这个年龄，
并不是一个，
实际的年龄，
因为你可以22岁，
但你觉得，
来不及了，
一切都太晚了，
我必须要，
赶紧进了大厂，
否则的话，
我的人生，
就要脱离轨道了，
对吧,
但是其实，
就像老远刚刚说的，
就是,
现在你看，
各式各样的人，
他们做各式各样的事，
他有一点点，
在那个，
小的领域里面的，
成就和，
接受到的关注，
他们都可以活，
就是,
如果玻璃，
很多这些，
社会的轨道的话，
你就以活，
送给自己的，
底线,
然后,
就像希希说的，
你无论是去，
追寻快乐，
你去追寻激情，
你感觉自己很年轻，
一切皆有可能，
就去尝试一些事情，
其实是OK的，
其实,
是一个打开的空间，
反而也许，
还能遇到一些惊喜，
嗯,
那最后，
我们再来读几封信，
有一位叫做，
巴巴托斯的朋友，
他说,
哎,
不知道别人毕业时，
是怎么想的，
但我和我朋友，
当时的状态是，
我们没有时间，
未分别难过，
我们都相信，
距离不是问题，
毕业后，
我们也会尽力，
互相分，
互相见，
每个人都充满干净，
要马上出门，
打下自己的一片天地，
更奇妙的是，
由于他们有着，
相似的思维方式，
毕业后，
都不在同一个行业，
相聚时，
交流,
却毫无障碍，
即使没有天天聊天，
还是无穷的，
共同语言，
真好,
你是一个，
很开心的武士，
那,
还有一位叫做，
Carmie Grace的朋友,。
哎,
是一个非常，
非常年轻的听众，
今年要高中毕业了，
其实有种不真实感，
之前总觉得，
上学度日如年，
现在只觉得，
时间过得好快，
不过呢，
我也没有变成，
功力的做体机器，
还是会写日记，
还是会阅读听歌，
看电影，
每个剩下来临，
还是没有忘记抬头，
看看凤凰话，
最后,
希望今年高考天气晴朗，
愿我上岸梦笑，
太棒了，
我们录的时候，
正好是在高考时间，
然后如果说有，
经历这个人生，
非常重要的，
这个夏天的朋友，
也祝你高考顺利，
当然,
不管考得怎么样，
我觉得人生的，
都非常的长，
是懂,
每一次毕业，
会有新的转机，
也都是新的开始，
那今天的节目，
我们就，
前前的聊到这里，
听众朋友们，
欢迎跟我们分享，
你的毕业心情，
如果你有任何的，
毕业时候，
你觉得应该知道的道理，
也欢迎在评论区留言，
那我们今天就，
聊到这里，
祝大家，
毕业开心，
开心,
拥抱快乐的暑假，
拜拜,